cherry gorgeous weather wasn't it
oh guys it was just uh we were sitting
out on the patio
i was filling out some last minute
things you know some
some santa stuff i had going on on the
patio yesterday
with the sun and 60s it was fabulous
this morning we've got a little change
in our skies though as we've got clouds
there and i showed you just going to
break here a few minutes ago
uh all of that beautiful color in the
sky we've widened the picture a little
bit
and you can see that we do have color on
the horizon a lot of clouds over
southern nevada right now
that's keeping temperatures really
pretty mild cool enough for jackets
don't get me wrong but i want to show
you the difference in the temperatures
because we're getting some breezy west
winds down at mountains edge
seven hills southern highlands uh those
temps in the mid to upper 50s but if you
look in the northeast valley at nellis
it's only 39 degrees we don't have
really much wind at all
and it's much cooler up in that part of
the valley 40s across most of the rest
of the valley
kyle canyon just had a wind gust to 40
miles an hour so
it is quite gusty through the mountains
red rock has just now had 30 mile an
hour wind gusts so
that's where we're going to look for the
winds today and then by tonight when
that cold front has moved through
high pressure will start to set up and
north winds will really start to blow
and we're going to get those winds going
tomorrow
for everyone in southern nevada high
clouds are being pulled up from the
south you can see them ahead of that
cold front
and that's what we've got this morning
wind advisories these areas of blue
for southern and eastern clark county
does not include las vegas
or para southern night county tomorrow
but for everywhere from prim to
searchlight to laughlin up to mesquite
near mesquite not quite but near
mesquite tomorrow wind advisory 7 a.m to
6 p.m we're looking at 40 to 50 mile per
hour winds tomorrow
our normal high is 56 we're still
looking at upper 60s today
a sunny and windy tomorrow much cooler
back into the normal mid 50s
clouds for christmas eve so santa's
gonna have to use a little radar to get
to where he's going thursday night
and then sunny for christmas day 60
degrees beautiful christmas day
clouds return on sunday for a chance of
showers maybe
on monday all right